あ〜〜眠〜〜
あ、あ～、、、ねむ！
みなさんおはよう！！
これまじ本当に多分３時間くらいしか寝てないですー。。
みなさんふりかけご存知でしょうか？？
普通にご飯食べても
ご飯って白ご飯…
白ご飯苦手でしょ？
白ご飯苦手な人って結構多いとおもうんですけども…
朝は皆さん朝ご飯食べた方が良いですよ。食べないと太ります
朝ご飯なんですけども、どうせご飯を食べるんだったらおいしく食べたいじゃないですか。
白ご飯をおいしく食べる方法としては
味付けがある訳でございます
で、その白ご飯の味付けの代表格として、
ふりかけがありますよね？
今回
ドン・キホーテに売ってるすべてのふりかけをゲットしてきました！
これまぁ、おおくね？地味にあったっすわ…
僕は知ってるんですよ…　ふりかけって
美味しいんですよ(^o^)
別に僕、白ご飯でも食いますよ。むしろ白ご飯好きですもん！
最近は食べませんけど……
ふりかけって、
おいしくないのないじゃないですか！！
ご飯ですよとかかけたら100%おいしいですもん！
あ！！　　もう
とりたまごそぼろをかけても100%美味しい！
わ！！！
赤しそふりかけなんてかけたら絶対美味しいですよ！
はずれがない！！！
あぁもうしそわかめとかも絶対かけたら美味しい
というわけで
僕の経験上、ふりかけってじつはとっても美味しいんですよ
そこでわたしはおもった！！
全部混ぜて食ったら、100%美味しい説
はい、というわけで
えーっと、あれ、なんか、え？
なんで水入ってる？？
はい、というわけでこちらの瓶にふりかけを入れていきましょう！
じゃ、ちょっといれていきましょう。まずはおかかふりかけ
ほんとただのおかかだよ
おとなのふりかけ明太子　あぁ
おとなのふりかけ鮭わかめ　あぁ
おとなのふりかけうめゆかり　おぉ
かつおみりん　うぅん
にくみそ！　うぅん
たらこ　えぇぇ
つけやか
のりたま
あじどうらく
たけふりたけ
赤しそふりかけ　うぇぇぇ
とりたまごそぼろ　うぉう
なめし　あぁ…
きもちわりっ！
ごましお　あ！いれすぎちゃった
山椒ふりかけ
やきにくのふりかけです
にんにくふりかけ　あぁ
ポン酢ふりかけ
のり弁のね、したにひくやつです
すっぱムーチョ梅ふりかけ
カラムーチョふりかけ
とりたまごそぼろ、なんかおなじのあったな…てか一緒やんけ！！
カレーふりかけ絶対美味しいやん…
辛子明太子
プチッとマグロ
ん？
おまえだれだよ！！
やめとこうかな…これなんかふりかけじゃないな
ごはんですよとプチッとマグロはなんかどろっとしてるんですよね…
どろっとしてるとさ、結局なんかどろっとしてるこいつ達にふりかけがくっついちゃうんで、あんたたちは失格ということで…
ほんとにさらさらっとかけれるものだけをふりかけっていう定義でやっていきましょう
…なんかここだけ真面目なんだよな……
野菜ふりかけ
ちりめん山椒
のりたま　あぁあ
ゆず胡椒　あぁ！
豚生姜焼き味　あぁ！
次、肉じゃがのふりかけ
うあぁ！やばっでた、焼き肉のたれのふりかけ
…あぁ！入れすぎた
とりからのふりかけ　あ！入れすぎた
あじよせ
わぁ…
牡蛎のごまふりかけ
coco壱のふりかけ
あぁ、入れすぎた
梅ごま塩
あぁ…
かつおふりかけ
しそわかめ
ゆかり
あぁ～　入れすぎた
あぁ～！入れすぎた…
超（スーパー）鶏そぼろ
鶏そぼろって美味いんだよね
あぁ！入れすぎた
で、最後！　納豆ふりかけです
納豆まで入んのか…　うわぁ…
はいっ！っというわけで完成しました
（バンッ）
はいっ！っというわけで完成してしまいましたが
なんか…凄いですね
もぉ…味の見当が全くつかない
もぉ…何種類の味を入れたんだろう
ただ、どれも間違いなく美味しいっていうのは
僕、知ってるんで
全部混ぜて、果たしてまず美味しいのか
美味しくないのか
そして、何味になるのか
やっていこうと思います！
しっかりまずは、
ちゃんと全部混ぜなきゃいけないんで
混ぜていきましょう
あぁもう完璧に混ざってると思います
出来ました！
これが全てのふりかけを混ぜた
最強のふりかけ…だと思います
さぁ～
果たして
何味になるのでしょうか
ご飯炊いてきます！
はいっ、では早速頂きたいと思います
味気無さっていうのはどうしても
あると思うんで…
そこにかけるふりかけが
いかに美味しくできるかって
結構、大事だと思うんですよね
じゃあ、かけていきましょう！
わぁ…これかけるのムズっ！
ちゃんと味を知りたいんで
ちょっと、多めにかけますね
あぁ～
なんかもうほんとに…
いろんな…
じゃあ、あとは
美味しいかどうかでございます
あと、味だなぁ…
果たして、ふりかけ全部混ぜると
何味になるのでしょうか
いただきます！
匂いが…
すいません、
表現出来ません！
なんだこれ…
（もぐもぐ…）
（！！）
美味いっ！
味のバラつきが酷い…
なんだろ別に
食べにくい訳じゃないんですよ
普通に美味しいとは思うんですけど…
なぁにこれ
なんかもう、分かんねぇ
しょっぱいし、甘いし、辛いし
苦いし、すっぱいし…
いろんな味があって分かりません
もう、風味もバラバラだから
なんなん、なっ、何！
異常に具だくさんなカレー
みたいな匂いがします
ふりかけは
まぜだっだめ
あっ…
ふりかけは…
混ぜちゃダメだzo★